hey guys how's it going this is gonna be
a very quick video but this has been a
very highly requested question that I
get all the time not only do I get this
question online but I get it in actual
real life out in the wild that question
is where did you get your backpack I'm
using this backpack for almost a year
now and I am obsessed with it now not
only do I have this backpack but I have
another one as well these two I have
pretty much had in rotation over the
past two years there by lounge fly this
is not sponsored and actually bought me
this one for my birthday last year and
then shortly after I got this one
because I loved this one so much this
one has cartoon baby star wars
characters on it and of course this one
has a beautiful stormtrooper pattern on
it
I'm obsessed and I'm making this video
mostly because people have been asking
me so much where I get them one of the
things that I've been struggling with
for a very long time is trying to find
the perfect mini backpack one that I can
fit all of my items in it not be too big
but not be too small this is the perfect
size one thing that I do wish that it
had it was some sort of a pocket inside
because right now you've only got two
pocket you've got this big one and then
this small one and because I'm paranoid
I don't like to put my wallet inside
here because someone can easily just
open that up if you're walking and take
it right out so I like to have that
hidden inside so if there was an inside
zipper part that would be so incredible
is that I wouldn't have to be paranoid I
mean right now all someone's gonna steal
this chapstick if they get in here
so because I've been using these for the
past year I wanted to see if they had
any more and guess what they have so
many this company I feel like has bought
the rights to pretty much everything
Marvel Pokemon if there's something that
you're into they probably have it not
only to give backpacks they have tiny
little purses and clutches they have so
many things it's kind of overwhelming
but for me I'm a backpack fan and I
gotta show you guys the two new ones
that I just got oh well wasn't the best
reveal ever what here they are this one
specifically when I saw this I started
freaking out this one has to be fairly
new because I never saw it and I've been
searching probably the past year just
for something else that I liked as much
as I like these two I really like this
one this is the Darth Vader backpack
because it's all black and it pretty
much matches anything but unless I'm
wearing Rebel Alliance gear I don't
really think I'm gonna be mad
as much because this color scheme is way
easier to match I mean clearly if I'm
wearing Star Wars backpacks that
probably I'm not really that concerned
with if things are matching or not but
either way you guys are probably gonna
see these and instagrams you're gonna
see them on Twitter and now you know if
someone Google's where to just even get
her backpack this video will show up and
I will have all the answers and all of
the links in the description again not
sponsored but honestly you guys have
been asking so much and I feel like
these are so perfect for all of you I
love the new Pokemon one that they have
it's black like this but it has a little
pokeballs all over it I had to draw the
line somewhere so I put these two and I
feel like I'm set for quite a while so
let me know what you guys think do you
guys have a favorite I'm not really sure
which one I like the best because I feel
like all of these are so different it
really depends on what my outfit is I
wonder if they have a bb-8 one wait a
minute is this a mini backpack they do
have a bb-8 mini school backpack as well
but I don't think it's as small as this
one is though I don't need it I don't
need it I don't need it you don't need
it you don't need it well thank you guys
so much for watching I will see you in
my next video let me know what you guys
think of these backpacks do you already
have one do you have any of other lounge
fly products if so let me know in the
comments below and I'm so sorry if
you're gonna go shopping now but don't
worry it's worth it
you
[Music]